hey guys what's up everybody
I'm on the show yes
I'm on the show yeah not really the war
between Matt Damon and Jimmy Kimmel
wages on he's a terrible human being
he's a terrible human being he's a
demonstrably bad man how long till you
guys he finally comes on you dedicate a
whole night to Matt Damon you let him
come on and you guys just air things out
I just can't imagine it happening I
really can I think we have been on
that'll be as close as we got yeah Ben
was on the comedians late night show
Tuesday celebrating the upcoming release
of his new flick air we have like the
whole all the great people from the cast
on the show
this week you're you're leaving someone
else what do you mean no I'm no I mean
there's you know well I mean there's
this you know Matt Damon's the lead of
the movies no I said all the best I said
all the great people from the film I
wasn't I didn't mean all the people then
please with Jimmy to make peace with his
bestie and eventually the late night
host agrees to a quick Face Time as a
belated wedding gift to Ben of course
he's probably available
hey guys what's up everybody I'm on the
show yes and Jimmy thank you for calling
uh Hey man that was that was very big of
you that whatever this is a gift to Ben
and JLo only not to you but despite
Ben's best efforts things don't go as
planned when the Wi-Fi signal gets
suspiciously wonky
wait is something wrong did you no Matt
did you put a filter on me
no what is going on are you doing this
you know I know I knew you were gonna
post something dumb like you're such a
child I'm so sick and tired of dealing
with you so why don't you drink am I a
hot dog am I am I an actual hot dog
right now is that even a real question
you know what why don't you take your
little question and your little show and
shove it up your big hairy ass
I'd expect nothing more from him I
wouldn't expect him to be kind of a
bigger man about any of this yeah that
kind of anger goes back decades in 2005
during season three of Jimmy Kimmel Live
the late night host started the gag by
ending his show with sincere apologies
to Matt Damon we ran out of time for him
tonight apologies to Matt Damon we ran
out of time Matt Damon apologies ran out
of time but he could have said Brad Pitt
he could have said you know George he
could have said somebody else but he
just for some reason maybe I had a movie
out that week or something but he just
said my name and and it changed the
course of both of our lives and ever
since they've taken jab after jab after
jab at each other
and that's right
sorry dummy we can't hear anything
you're saying you can sit there all
night long for all I care you think you
could throw the football through that
window
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa what the hell is
this
do you live here what the hell is going
on here
hey hey why are you touching me well I'm
not touching you oh
Ben can try all he wants but this Feud
has no sign of slowing down hey I'd love
to take a picture with you but we ran
out of time oh I know who that guy is
yeah it's that guy from them yeah I know
that from the ponytail movie stay in
fight are you ever gonna kiss and make
up with Kimmel no no he's an
why would I ever do that
[Music]